he seems lovely she's happy as can be
Julie Bowen gushes over her Modern
Family daughter Sarah Highlands new beau
in case you haven't heard Sarah Hyland
is dating Wells Adams known for the
Bachelorette and bachelor in paradise
he's like the nicest prettiest best
person and Sarah's on-screen mom Julie
well she approves of this reality star
romance I have not met him I can only
say I was in on the ground floor of the
flirting
he seems lovely he seems like a really
nice guy and he treats it really well
and she's happy as can be so you know
that's all you can watch her for your
daughter's fake her real Edie spoke with
the actress at the baby to baby gala
presented by Paul Mitchell where Gwyneth
Paltrow was honored what makes for the
perfect honoree for tonight well I mean
she isn't is she's like the perfect mom
and you know she she's always in a
social conscience she's always talked
about giving back she raised his kids
who was seen you know so far they don't
they haven't gotten arrested like she
seems to have good good family values
and his concerns but giving back and
Bowen also praised Paltrow for speaking
out about the allegations of sexual
harassment against Harvey Weinstein
Paltrow claimed in October that
Weinstein acted inappropriately with her
when she was 22 what has been your
reaction to that and how can we move
this conversation forward I'm afraid
that the real and very genuine
conversation about how women are
disempowered by society as a whole but
especially in Hollywood is getting lost
in the gossip of who's the next bust I'm
waiting for that to kind of settle down
for a minute
[Music]
you